فيضانات وسيول جارفه اجتاحت عددا من
المحافظات جنوبيه تركيا ما ادى الى مقتل
عدد من الاشخاص في محافظه اديمان وارفا
هنا في محافظه اورفا تشاهدون كيف غمرت
مياهو الفيضانات والسيول عشرات المنازل
عشرات المدنيين كانوا محاصرين في هذه
المنازل لكن فرق الانقاذ والطوارئ التركيه
اجلتهم الى اماكن امنه بعد ان كانوا
محاصرين فيها تشاهدون كذلك كيف غمرت مياه
الفيضانات العديد من الشوارع في هذه
المنطقه من محافظه اورفا وكذلك جرفت
المياه عشرات السيارات والحقت اضرارا
واسعه في هذه المنطقه ومعظم الاضرار في
محافظه اورفا تركزت في المناطق المنخفضه
منها فرق اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
ما تزال تعمل حتى الان من اجل البحث عن
المفقودين ومن اجل كذلك تصريف مثل هذه
المياه المتجمعه الشوارع من اجل فتح
الشوارع وتصريف المياه منها الى الجداول
والقنوات الموجوده في المدينه
العمل مستمر منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر ولما
ينتهي بعد
المسؤولون هنا يتحدثون بان هنالك العديد
من المدنيين المفقودين الذين جرفتهم مياه
الفيضانات وما يزال البحث عنهم مستمرا
الوضع بشكل عام يجمله محافظ الضيمان بان
ما حل بهذه المنطقه كارثه جديده لحقت
بالمحافظات الجنوبيه خصوصا هنا في محافظه
اورفا واوديمان
وهاتين المحافظتين كانتا من المناطق
المنكوبه بعد الزلزال الذي ضربهما في
السادس من شباط الماضي هيئه الارصاد
الجويه كذلك حذرت المواطنين من ان المياه
الامطار سوف تستمر خلال الايام القادمه
لذلك هنالك توصيات للمدنيين من اجل عدم
الاقتراض من المنازل المتضرره وعدم البقاء
كذلك في المنازل
والطوابق السفليه عمر حلبي الجزيره من
محافظه اورفا جنوبيه تركيا